PRESENTER: I am very pleased to
welcome to Google today Nelly
Ben Hayoun.
Nellie is a fearless and
passionate provocateur
who was nominated
by "Icon" magazine
as one of the 50 international
designers shaping the future.
She is the designer
of experiences
at SETI, the Search for
Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
And in 2014 "WIRED"
magazine awarded
Nellie with a "WIRED" Innovation
Fellowship for her work
and its potential to
make a significant impact
on the world.
Her latest film,
"Disaster Playground,"
has original music
from the prodigy,
and it unveils the
real-life chain of command
if an asteroid was
to hit the Earth.
It's got its UK premiere on
June 30 at the BFI in London
and will be available
on all digital platforms
after that, including
Google Play.
So please join me in a
massive round of applause
and welcome to the
stage, Nelly Ben Hayoun.
[APPLAUSE]
NELLY BEN HAYOUN:
Merci beaucoup.
Thanks for the
lovely introduction.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, Googlers.
So, yes, I guess I kind of put
this slide really big up there,
so you're kind of
aware that I've got
a very strong French accent.
And I'm really sorry about this.
You know, I've been here
for about nine years.
But it's still as
strong as it gets, huh?
And what is going to
happen, just now for you,
is going to be an
intense bombardment
of different [INAUDIBLE],
everything we do in the studio,
basically.
But I'm going to just keep
on getting more and more
passionate, as it
goes, and I'm going
to go more and more faster.
So just be prepared
mentally for this.
And if it doesn't
make any sense to you,
can just raise your
hands in the air,
and I will try and
like slow it down.
But I don't promise anything.
Anyway, so let me introduce
you a bit more to my practice.
So I'm going to start by giving
you a bit more for background
and then we will get into
the core of what we do
in the studio, which is pretty
extreme as we like to call it.
So I created the
studio back in 2009.
And the idea of the studio
was to try and figure out
how can we really get members
of the public engaged.
And, you know, I come
from a design world, OK?
I'm a designer by training.
And I always find
it pretty difficult
as a designer to actually get
members of the public really
fascinated by a table or
a chair or actually get
them really engaged with a cause
or with research that I think
is very important.
So it kind of became sort of
a rotating thing in my head.
And I was, like, how
on earth can we really
try and get members of the
public engaged with a cause?
How can we do that?
And then the other
kind of problem I had
was also this notion
of "hyperreal."
"Hyperreal" is this word which
was coined by Baudrillard.
So if you don't know him,
he's a French sociologist.
Don't worry, I don't just
have French references,
but this one is pretty good.
So Baudrillard came up with
that word of "hyperreal."
And what it is is this
idea that, in a way,
you know, if you look at this
example-- and I'm a space geek,
so you're only going
to see space stuff.
But if you look at
this, everything
is NASA nowadays-- Super 8 NASA,
NASA Laundrymat, NASA Liquor.
You even have the Apollo
Tire and Wheel Shop.
And, really, this
idea of "hyperreal"
is this idea that in a way
nothing has any meaning today.
So if you want to get
members of the public engaged
with a cause when they
have a multitude of offers
on the table, they
don't really tend
to actually engage really
physically with anything.
So how can we do that?
And I started to
think, well, you
know, I come from also
different backgrounds.
So I got training as a designer,
but I also trained as a painter
before that.
And before that, I was also
making kimonos in Japan.
So I've got this sort of
strange mix of things, right?
But we all do.
But, for me, I've
always been fascinated
to actually look at a painting
and how a painter actually
brings in all their discipline
into their practice.
So, for example, in
the case of Manet--
but you can take all the
Renaissance as well--
you get this famous painting
in which this woman is looking
at you, but on the back you can
see the scene that either she's
dreaming of or the
scene that is actually
the perspective of the mural.
But what I'm seeing
there is like there
is sort of a scene in a scene.
There is an architecture
which is there.
So it's like the 2D becomes 3D.
And that is very
interesting, right?
This whole mix of different
disciplines into one.
And then if you
look even further,
there is actually one
of my favorite painter
called Luc Tuymans.
He's talking about
painting as being something
which is very hard to remember.
And what he's saying
about that, he's saying,
well, look, when you
go into a museum,
you don't tend to
remember a painting,
but you will try and
remember the tone of it.
And actually the tone can really
remain in someone's memory.
And that's what I think
is very interesting.
So how can you sort of bring
in a tone or bring in a paste
to a design product
or to something
that will sort of talk to
all of us to some extent?
How can you do that?
Is this even possible?
And I started at that time also
taking some classes in theater.
And one of those things
that always fascinated me is
commedia dell'arte.
Do you know about
commedia dell'arte?
Are you awake?
Are you OK?
I know it is post-lunch.
But, you know, show
me a bit of the love.
So commedia dell-arte is this
satirical form from basically
the 17th century.
And the idea of commedia
dell'arte is you will have
extreme characters.
Usually, they have
a mask as well.
And it's pretty much structured.
They all have like some
sort of pattern that they
need to perform on stage.
But what is very interesting
is like all the improvisation
that are in between.
So it really is a
craft of improvisation.
That's what commedia
dell'arte is all about.
And again, I was like, well,
when you look at design, again,
how can we sort of bring in
that component of improvisation
or live event as well?
How can we bring this
into our practice?
And so you know, I
was spending my time
getting it into the head.
And that's what we
came up in the studio,
is design of experiences.
So you probably
wonder, what the heck
is a design of experiences?
Do you?
I hope you do.
Let's put it this way.
So the design of experiences is
really around these two axes.
So sorry, it's a
bit of background,
but then at least you will
know where I come from.
And hopefully, it will
make sense to you.
But it comes from
critical design.
And I'm going to tell you
a few more words about it.
But it's also combining it with
a component more of the range
of the live event, like
the theatre of cruelty.
Again, I'm going to tell you
a few more words about it.
Are you excited about this?
All these things at Google are
so as, you know, in the search.
But if you don't know
about critical design,
it really started in 1999.
And it was coined into a
book called "Hertzian Tales"
by Professor Anthony Dunne
and Fiona Raby, his partner.
And they actually started
this course at the Royal
College of Art called Design
Interactions, which actually
some of you have done, I know.
And I also come from there.
And what I found
really interesting
about the whole practice
of critical design
is this idea that as
a designer, usually
you would do the A list.
So the A list is usually
problem-solving approach.
Here is a problem, and
here is a response to it.
I mean, I'm kind of
oversimplifying it.
I'm not saying that this
is just what designers do.
But that's one component.
But as a critical designer,
what you would do is actually,
you would take more of a
problem-finding approach.
So you would try and think
about nanotechnology,
scientific biology,
all the new technology
that we have nowadays,
and you would
like to think about how that
might change our everyday
into the next 5, 10 years.
And you would try to
think about actually
what problem might raise in it.
And in a way, the
product becomes a debate
that you're going to be doing.
That's the ultimate goal
of a critical designer,
is to design a
platform for debate
for members of the public.
And in a way, it
makes sense, right?
A product can also be a debate.
And that's also means
that we work a lot
within the field of fiction.
We work a lot with futurists.
We work in
pluridisciplinary teams.
That's where this
component comes from.
Now, Antonin Artaud is
coming way back forward.
I like to have a mix
of different reference.
But Antonin Artaud really,
20th century dramaturge,
came up with this title
of the Theatre of Cruelty.
And the Theatre of Cruelty
is really this idea
that in a way, when
you come to see a show,
you always expect--
just like right now,
you just expect to
be quite passive.
You take in the information.
And that is fine.
Nothing is going
to happen to you.
Now, Antonin Artaud
tried to reverse this.
He's saying, well,
actually, you're
coming to see me on stage,
but I'm going to vomit on you.
I'm going to vomit on you.
I'm going to throw you
blood on the face, water.
I'm going to try and
shake you out your body.
I'm going to actually get this
sort of violence out of you
so we can actually really have
this conversation from what
is happening on stage
and what is happening
within the public sphere.
So what I'm saying to you is not
that in Nelly Ben Hayoun studio
we are vomiting on our
clients, not at all.
But what I'm saying is we like
to take this kind of quite
dramatic, let's say, approach,
quite visceral way to things,
where maybe you
might want to expand
something we are designing, but
we don't leave you the choice.
It is just happening.
So this is how we would
define it, really.
The design of experiences
is this notion
of engineering a situation.
And if some of you want to
look a bit more into this,
there is also
situationists as well
that's created this all
engineering of situation
before.
So it's not new, some new ideas.
The engineering of
a situation that
can generate disorder
and critical thinking,
both in an institution
and amongst members
of the general public.
So that's the idea.
Now, what is actually
what we are doing?
So really, when you think
about the creative process,
you would think about
chaos at the initial part.
Like it's usually a
bombardment of ideas.
You would take
some bits from-- I
don't know-- the film
industry, some bits from there,
and you would mix them up.
You would start to look
at different references,
and you would come
up with an idea.
Now, for us, chaos
comes at the beginning
of the creative
process, and it also
comes at the end of the creative
process, in the delivery.
So in a way, chaos is also
made up of public engagement.
And I hope that
makes sense to you.
And we will get
there in a second.
But total bombardment is another
component of the way we work.
So what does that mean,
total bombardment?
I'm going to get to it as well.
But that means that in a
way, we do not tell a product
or we do not tell a story
just through one channel.
We look at feature film.
We look at book.
We look at app.
We look at exhibition.
And we will sort of spread out
the work and the narratives
through all of these different
channels to actually really,
like I said, total bombard you.
So there is no way out.
It's like it's a total
holistical experience.
And really, what we do is we
like to aim for the impossible.
We love really large-scale
production where everybody's
telling you-- and mainly all
the funders and clients--
it's impossible.
And just because this is
impossible, we will do it.
So the crew is also
reflecting this.
It's a pluridisciplinary crew.
We've got people coming from the
engineering background, people
from the art background,
people from the research
background, science background.
And it's all basically
mixed up together,
which obviously means that
we can argue quite a lot,
but that's part of the process.
Now, just to come back to
this idea of total bombardment
and sort of spreading out
narratives in different fields,
if you want to do
that, you also need
to have the credits to
be-- like if you want
to talk to a
scientific audience,
you need to have
the credits within
that scientific audience.
If you want to get to a
film audience involved,
you need to have the credit
for that specific world to.
So a lot of what we
do, also, is to try
and actually collaborate
with an institution
that we know will have really
interesting-- will bring
a really interesting
component to the project
or an interesting content to it.
So to this end, back since
like now three years,
I'm working with
the SETI Institute
as a designer of experiences.
If you don't know about
the SETI Institute,
it's the Search for
Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
It was created in 1986.
And the idea of
the SETI Institute
was to say, well, look,
we might not be alone.
We might not be alone.
There might be other
things out there.
And we should better
find out, actually,
and we should better spend
some time researching this.
So the SETI Institute is really
divided in two components--
the SETI Search,
which is about looking
for signals coming from other
potential civilizations.
And then you've got the other
part, which is astrobiology,
which is really about finding
life on other planets.
So that can be bacteria.
That can be anything
that we can consider
as life nowadays-- extremophiles
or things like that.
And that, to me, has
always been fascinating,
because in there, you get to
all the most pioneer scientists.
People really try and break
down the scale of what science
can actually provide us with.
And what that bring us-- well,
it's like all new perspective
to the work we are doing.
We are not just
doing it for here,
but we're also looking at
the scale of the universe
and what is happening out there.
Now, we're also involved with
the International Astronautical
Federation.
I'm a member of the Space
Education and Outreach
Committee.
It's a very
interesting place to be
if you want to play a
role, also politically,
with the decisions which are
being taken in the space field
and with space agencies.
It's where I can actually
share these ideas
and we can actually
discuss about maybe
there is another way to get
members of the public involved
with space exploration
than getting them to draw
a cosmonaut or things that.
There might be something
else that we can do
which is a bit more in depth.
Let's put it this way.
So now, we also collaborate
with WeTransfer since now--
when did it start?
In 2011, and their
head of experiences.
And so if you don't
know about WeTransfer,
that is a free file
transfer service
that allows you to share files.
And as you do so, you've
got this background that
keeps on flipping through it.
Now, it's been very interesting
for me to collaborate
with WeTransfer in
the sense that you
can bring in content as well
through this background.
You can bring a new
article by "The Guardian."
You can bring the research of
this man here, for example.
You click.
You get to his website.
And WeTransfer has 66 million
active users, all digital,
which obviously is a very
interesting conversation
that you can get with them.
And then "WIRED," more
recently, in which
we started to actually get
to speak to another audience
as well.
So now what do you?
What do we do?
What do you do, we know.
But what do we do?
You probably want to know that.
Or do you want?
Yes?
OK, good.
So we go in the
field a lot, right?
I mean, in that case,
for example, with CERN,
we went to visit the Large
Hadron Collider, which
is this place where you bombard
protons at the speed of light.
Think about it.
Bombard protons at
the speed of light
to recreate the first
second of the Big Bang.
Isn't it fascinating?
It's so amazing, right?
But what about us?
What about all of us?
How does it feel to be
one of the scientists
when you're switching
on a machine like this?
And so that's how the
approach really started there,
is that I went to see them.
I said, look, this is
amazing, what you do.
But then how can we get
a bit of that magic back
into our kitchen
sink, for example?
So we worked
together for a year.
We looked at different type
of physics experiments,
many-- the Casimir experiment,
if you're looking into physics.
But I'm not going to go
into details of the physics.
But that's what we did there.
And we tried and reproduce it
with the meaning of nowadays.
So, for example, this lady
is using a microwave gun,
which is pretty dangerous.
Obviously, we reworked some
component of the experiment.
But that's the idea, right?
As a member of the
public, you can now
generate a picometer,
which is close to nothing,
but of dark energy, which is
74% of the universal, so total
unknown.
So in a way, you can
generate a bit of unknown
while you're eating your
pancake in your kitchen.
Isn't it amazing?
That's what we want to do if
we were given the opportunity.
Now, here is another
experiment where
fantastical things happen.
It's in Japan.
It's called the
Super Kamiokande.
It's a neutrino observatory.
Now, what is happening
there is eventually,
you've got a particle
meeting another one.
It creates a huge
explosion, which
is called a sonic boom when a
particle is traveling faster
than the speed of
light in a vacuum.
And all of this is amazing,
but what about us, again?
So we worked with them and
with the physicists who
are working on the experiment.
And we told them,
look, how can we
give this as an experience
for a member of the public?
But obviously, we come at it
from a theatrical perspective
and a design perspective, too.
So that means that we will
work the soundtrack with them.
We will work the light
effect with them.
We will try and reproduce very
accurately what you actually
inside the tank.
But then there is
component of it
which are left to
improvisation, of course,
because you do not want to
bombard a member of the public
with the science.
You also want them
to be in the maze
of going through this journey
in which they can experience
something which is close to
an out of body experience.
It's very violent,
that project, actually.
You get very low frequency.
You've got your
entire body shaking up
when you go through it.
It's not very enjoyable.
But then obviously,
what we try and look
for is actually this moment of a
maze where the member of public
would tell you, is this real?
Is this fake?
What is this?
And then this is where
the engagement starts.
Now, we work a lot as
well with astronauts.
And one of them is
Jean Pierre Haignere,
who is a French
astronaut that lift off
three time from the Soyuz
rocket, three times or two
times.
I need to check that.
But basically, the idea
that I used to tell him,
well, look, if you're just
too small, you're too big,
you don't have the right
PhD, what are your chances
to make it in space, really?
Let's face it.
Not much.
So we went to see him.
And we said, look, can
we try and generate
a sort of a monster that you
can have in your living room,
like a [INAUDIBLE]
pretty much, that
would give you the entire
holistic experience of a Soyuz
rocket-- stage one, stage
two, stage three, and then
weightlessness.
Obviously, weightlessness
is a bit difficult
to put together in your
living room, but we tried.
So we did the
soundtrack with him.
We did everything tailored
to him, because remember
that if you're
designing experience,
you're not there to-- you
know, it's not interesting
if it's my own vision of what
a rocket liftoff is about.
It doesn't mean anything.
But if you get the
real expert involved,
and he's actually helping
you through the process
to actually make sure that
what you do is tangible,
then this is where it
becomes interesting.
At least that's what we think.
So here is the
stage, experiencing
one of the stage of
the rocket liftoff.
And I'm going to show you
a few extracts of people
going through their experience.
So, for example, as you can
see, it's a pretty loud object.
We killed every single
microphone with it.
But basically, here, these
people will go-- of course,
there is the whole part which
is about the performance
and making believe
that actually, you're
really going to
experience something
which is close to a
scientific experiment.
And then by the
moment you go in this,
you're actually really seeing
that you are experiencing
some form of weightlessness.
And you're actually really
believing something as simple
as that, that I'm actually
lifting you up somewhere.
And so, this lady, for
example, is saying,
I think it's very terrified.
I thought it was exciting
to go to the moon,
but it's actually really scary.
But when you get someone
who tells you this, you that
this is job done.
Because actually,
there is nothing
more scary than going
into a rocket liftoff.
You never know if you're
going to make it back or not.
So in a way, getting
that type of feedback
from a member of the
public is the best
you can get, really, for someone
who is designing experiences,
because that's what you
want from them, in a way.
So of course, it means that
there is a lot of trial,
and there is a lot
of improvisation
that comes with it.
But that's part of
our process, too.
And we accept that.
And so here is another
extreme project
in which we were
questioning what
the future of entertainment
might be like.
And doing all these projects,
I realized that actually,
as a member of the public,
you want things which
are more and more extreme.
Even Disney World now is
scary like hell when you think
about it, for a kid, really.
And you need to push
and push and push to get
that moment of thrill, really.
And in a way, we were looking at
that for this specific project
in which we are working with
volcanologists at Mount St.
Helens, which is a
volcano in the US.
And we reproduced [INAUDIBLE]
eruption of this volcano.
And it comes with
a power supply.
You push it into
your living room.
Obviously, it's scaled down.
The point is not to kill
you, but it will still
burn down quite a big
part of your living room.
And then what we did
is we put it online.
We say, who wants to
have this volcano?
And we weren't interested
really in term of the feedback.
We had more than
6,000 people who
wanted to have this thing
into their living room.
And of course, it's
starting this whole debate
about of course, what do we want
when it comes to entertainment,
and how much extreme do we
want to, actually-- it to be,
and whether or not we
should domesticate science
for this, and
specifically volcano,
or whether or not
we shouldn't do it.
So it's bringing up all
these ethical and also
political questions
to the table.
Now, here is our
latest project--
"Disaster Playground."
So "Disaster Playground"
is bringing up
all these different ideas
together into a feature film.
But [INAUDIBLE] we
are looking at is
when you think
about asteroid, you
would think about Bruce
Willis with a big drill,
ready to save all of us.
That's what we all
automatically think.
And if you think even further,
you would think, OK, well,
it's pretty much in hands.
NASA's got it in hands, or
[? ISSA's ?] got it in hands.
But someone must
have this in hands,
because we do not want to
finish like the dinosaurs.
Now, the reality's
a bit different.
And I didn't use that when
I started the project,
but I was really
interested in this notion
of how can we
actually bring back
the political mind together
with the scientific mind?
Because if you look
at, for example,
the atomic bomb, a lot of things
that they've been reproached
to Oppenheimer is
the fact that he
was so sublime by the
technology that, in a way,
he never thought about the cause
or what political implication
his discovery would do.
And there is this notion
since the Second World War
that in any case, scientists
do not have critical thinking.
And I wanted to actually come
up with a project in which we
will prove that they
have critical thinking.
So we needed to come up
with something quite extreme
in which they will be
forced to actually come up
with a political decision.
And so that's where this
whole scenario came up.
So we went all around the US to
meet with the chain of command,
the people who actually
have a real role
to play if an asteroid
was to strike.
And we went to meet them all.
We went all the way to the
White House, to the UN.
And here is a few extracts.
So we went to visit
the monitoring
device who are looking for
what is out there in the sky.
Here they are.
We looked at the
role of amateurs
into asteroid detection.
We met with the
Minor Planet Center
as well, the people who
are basically monitoring
the sky on daily basis.
We looked at the
detection technique.
Here is Mark Boslough.
He's working at the Sandia
National Laboratory,
which is a place where
originally the atomic bomb was
created.
So do we or shall we send
anything to actually burst
this thing in space?
We worked with astronauts,
notably Rusty Schweickart, who
was an Apollo 9 astronaut,
who actually is really
engaged with that
specific topic,
and he's one of the mentors
of the World Asteroid
Day, which I'm going to
tell you a bit more about.
We went all the way
to NASA headquarters,
met Lindley Johnson, and with
people who actually started
the NEO programs,
the Near-Earth Object
program, which is-- near-earth
objects is asteroids,
basically.
But it extends to more objects.
And then all the way to the UN.
And of course, we talked
as well with the people
who will have a role
to play on the ground.
And we trained with the
people from Disaster City.
So I don't now if you
know about Disaster City,
but it's the place where
all the teams worldwide
get teamed for disaster
type of scenario.
That's what it looks like.
So the entire technique
was, of course,
one of the Theatre of Cruelty.
I would turn up in office
with these props that
would put them under a
massive amount of pressure.
And hopefully, we
wanted to get back
to the core of how they
would react for real if we're
in this real situation.
So you can get that, right?
We are in a "what if"
situation that we've staged,
and we get them to actually
perform how they would really
react to it.
So here is a few of our props.
And then like I say, it's
not just a feature film.
It's also the booth,
the app, the exhibition.
And all of these stories are
being told at different levels
so a member of the
public can engage with it
at different components.
And I will come to it.
Now, I work a lot
with music, too.
And in this case, we worked
with Ed Banger Records,
which, if you don't
know them, they
produce Daft Punk, Justice,
and all these people.
And they actually compose
the music for the film.
And then we worked
with punk band Prodigy.
Prodigy, yes?
And then they actually
re-orchestrated
one of their music for the
International Space Orchestra,
which is an orchestra we have.
So anyway, I'm going to
show you the trailer, which
I hope you will enjoy.
And then we move
to the next step.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-At 0400 Pacific, we were
notified of a building collapse
to Building 239, cause unknown.
Reports indicate a pancake
collapse of three floors
to the ground level.
Proceed to the
scene immediately.
-This is what we know so far.
At 8:30 this
morning, an asteroid
impacted the county of Granger.
-Our team on the ground
are currently investigating
the subject matter.
If you can, shelter yourself.
-Catalina Sky Survey.
This is Eric.
-I can't believe this.
There's news here that an
asteroid just hit in Texas,
and it took out an entire town.
-It doesn't make any sense to
me what you're talking about.
-Asteroids.
-An asteroid?
-An asteroid!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-V, A, N, D, R,
O, I, D. V, A, N--
-David Morrison at Congress.
Action.
-We have the means
to protect our planet
if we choose to do so.
If we don't, we might go
the way of the dinosaurs.
-Asteroids are
definitely coming.
There is one that's
going to hit the Earth.
It's already set
on that trajectory.
We just don't know
which one it is.
So here's a
tremendous catastrophe
that can be prevented by
humans working and preserving
and modeling and preparing.
-We actually came
up with deep impact
before the movie came up
with their deep impact.
But they got a lot of
things right as opposed--
[INAUDIBLE]
-Although it's very
exciting to talk
about blowing up an asteroid
or pushing it or moving it,
what we need to do, before we
think about that is understand
what's the threat?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-V, A, N, D, R, O, I, D.
-So who would be Oppenheimer?
-Who would be Oppenheimer?
I don't know.
And I mean, I
don't think anybody
knew who Oppenheimer would
be prior to Manhattan Project
either.
Somebody would emerge.
-If we reject to do something,
and as a consequence,
millions of people die,
history will not forget.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--I, D. V, A, N, D, R, O, I, D.
V, A, N, D, R, O, I, D. V, A,
N, D, R, O--
-Can we use our big red phone?
-Uh.
-We don't use phone anymore.
-I'm not going to go there.
-I mean, is that true?
-Of course it's true.
I wouldn't say it
if it's not true.
-I can't do it.
-OK, I'll show you.
-Because you know
what would happen?
-Yes.
-We'd be dead.
There's nothing to
do at that point.
[BLIP]
-Nothing evokes the end of the
world more than a man running
straight ahead on
a beach swathed
in the sounds of his
Walkman, cocooned
in the solitary
sacrifice of his energy,
indifferent even to catastrophes
since he expects destruction
to come only as the
fruit of his own efforts
from exhausting the energy of
a body that has in his own eyes
become useless.
[BLIP]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
NELLY BEN HAYOUN: OK, it's
at the BFI on 30th of June,
but there will be
events everywhere.
And then we will release
it also on that day,
so the dates are all in
there and [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway, another thing I wanted
to tell you about as well,
because we are all about
music, too, in the studio,
we have an orchestra which is
based at NASA Ames Research
Center and the SETI Institute.
And it pretty much
looks like this.
It's about 60
members which are all
coming from
different departments
at NASA, SETI
Singularity University.
Basically, it's a
space community which
is based in Silicon Valley.
We want to extend
it others, but we
need to keep it within
something that we can actually
know where this is all going,
Anyway, the first
performance we actually
did with the International
Space Orchestra
was also looking
at when things go
terribly wrong in
mission control,
how do people actually do react?
And who are those sort
of heroes that manage
to find how to deal with it?
And in a way, it's
part of the story when
it comes to the craft
of space exploration
that we don't know much about.
Because actually, if you look
at the communication that
is being done by most
of the space agencies,
like we will share
all the successes,
but when there is problem,
we don't share that.
And it makes sense,
you might think.
But actually, if you go
back in time with the Greek,
for example, they used to
have this old dramatic session
where they would
get a chorus that
would sing the difficulties
to be in politics.
It was called the
politeia, and it
would be like the
pathos live on stage,
and they would sing
the difficulties
of being a politician.
Now, that created
a bit of sympathy,
or empathy, I would say,
by a member of the public.
If it is difficult,
then I can understand.
If it's only success,
success, success,
how can I feel for you in a way?
So we tried to put
this together in music.
And then here we are actually
having Bobby Womack, Damon
Albarn to compose the music.
Maywa Denki is a Japanese
composer; Bruce Sterling.
who is a science fiction
author that came with his wife
Jasmina Tesanovic to perform
as part of the orchestra
at Penguin Cafe with UK,
really beautiful jazz band.
Evan Price was our
music director,
who is a genius, really.
Because when you think
about it, all of them
didn't know each other at
the beginning of the project.
And also, I'm not a musician,
so I just pick them up.
Oh, you play a triangle?
Come in the orchestra.
Oh, you play the dobro?
Come in it.
Oh, you play-- so it's like it's
an absolute mix of instruments.
So pretty much to
actually sound harmonic,
you need to have
quite a skill there.
And that was the one of Evan.
So here is one of our
members, Yvonne Gagle,
who is an astronaut.
And then, of
course, like I said,
it doesn't make sense for me to
direct it without the expert.
I do not know how
the voice tone needs
to be like when you perform
inside a mission control.
I needed some help.
Therefore, we
directed it together
with Rusty Hunt, who is a flight
director at NASA and Astronaut
Gagle to actually get
this as right as possible.
And then they were positioned
like they were in the Mission
Control of the Apollo 11 mission
because we reenact the Apollo
11 mission.
And it was part
scripted, part perform.
And then here,
they are performing
in front of the world's
largest [INAUDIBLE].
We eventually got to
record at Skywalker.
I don't know if I
have time to show
you the extract from the feature
film, maybe a tiny bit of it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I pretty much feel like if
I'm an astronaut right now.
The International Space
Orchestra, it's a world for us,
right?
It's never been done before.
I mean, NASA Ames is
such a messy place--
2,500 researchers.
So it's as well bringing
this whole event together.
So then we can all meet
and make something happen.
Yes, it's going to
be very enjoyable.
But then also, it's going
to be quite odd work.
So I just hope that you're
all going to take part in this
and take it with
the right attitude.
-You remind me of
a good con artist.
-[LAUGHS].
-A good what?
-You know what a con artist is?
-Someone who can sell
anything to anybody.
-Test tubes, go. [INAUDIBLE] go.
Ethanol spray, go.
Capcom, we are go
for power descend.
-We're here.
We're here.
We're on the moon.
This is it.
That should almost be-- every
word is just like a crystal
coming though.
The eagle has landed.
-I'm kind of a perfectionist.
And I'm a pretty
high energy person.
-You know, science
is black and white.
Music probably isn't.
But it still takes a
creative mind to do it.
-When we go wherever we're going
to go-- be it Mars or beyond--
you have to take the
human spirit with you,
or we won't survive or
thrive where we're going.
-I mean, they're never going to
be the Philharmonic, all right?
But that's not the point.
[END PLAYBACK]
-We did this project.
And then since every year,
new performance, new composer,
new scene.
Lately, it was with Beck at
the Davies Symphony Hall.
And actually, they're
getting better and better.
They just got a
standing ovation,
so I was very happy for
them, because a lot of them
had to make a choice
between going into music
or actually going into science.
So it was, for them,
a bit of a moment.
And then we eventually got
this music that we recorded
at Skywalker-- which is a place
where they recorded "Star Wars"
initially, right?-- to be
sent in space, of course,
where it's actually
since August,
orbiting the Earth on one
of these nanosatellites,
which are run by Nanosatisfi,
Spire if you're interested
in nanosattelites.
And then here they are orbiting
and singing from there.
And then currently,
we are working
on a new extreme project where
we are looking for partners.
So if you're interested
in joining us in this new
expedition, which is pretty cold
and very deep down in the sea,
I cannot say much about it,
but it involves Viking ship,
underwater discoveries,
something, something,
something.
So here you go.
So that's where you will see
all our things in the next year
or so.
Voila!
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you.